at the end of the day
trauma disconnects somebody from
themself
the way you described it that I have
trouble feeling I have trouble
connecting with my emotions is a perfect
way to to explain that and if somebody
hasn't been abused they haven't
experienced childhood trauma they
haven't experienced big trauma they
don't really understand what it feels
like to
literally be walking down the street and
feel disconnected from your own feet
or
to feel like your body's on fire just
because you have a two-year-old crawling
all over you or
um you just want to scream and run out
of the house just because your kids are
laughing too loud it's this
disconnection from yourself to the goal
of any sort of
therapeutic intervention is
to reconnect with yourself